this is what's left after a suspected
rampage by the armed group Boko Haram in
the Nigerian city of Maiduguri charred
bodies and burnt vehicles at least 30
people were killed while travelling
overnight in the town of Allah on a
major highway
in Borno State witnesses say most of the
victims were burnt to death while
sleeping in their cars we were just
sitting in the front seat of the car and
heard them shouting god is great
and then the shooting began they first
killed a lady in the front seat of the
car and then we started running away
they also burned two babies and abducted
a number of men and women the victims
missed a 5 p.m. curfew to pass a gate
leading to Maiduguri
they were forced to stay in our know
after the military reportedly shut the
road but our town has come under attack
before and that angered the residents
here who want answers while President
Muhammadu Buhari has condemned the
attacks the governor of Borno State says
there isn't enough support given by the
authorities to protect the people we
military establish our unity in our law
the iron is 5 o clock the clothes
decayed there's no people the army has
promised to rectify this we will fix the
problem we are working for you not for
us and we will make sure we continue
doing that while there's been no claim
of responsibility Boko Haram has been
fighting an insurgency in Nigeria for
the past decade the city of Maiduguri
used to be a stronghold of the armed
group but government forces have since
driven them out the area has also become
a target of the Islamic state in West
Africa its own internal operations and
in terms of building our cooperation
with neighboring states it's a difficult
environment you know the challenges
further to the north in the Sahel
burkina faso the continuing uncertainty
in libya and broader changes in terms of
Islamist violence in Syria and
I think create a space that I think in
the less well governed parts of Nigeria
particularly in the Northeast violent
extremists have been able to exploit the
violence in the Northeast has become all
too common for the people here and many
continue to live in constant fear Rahila
mohammed al jazeera